right good evening everybody and welcome
to Development Committee 21st of March
2019 our usual emergency evacuation
announcement first should we be required
to evacuate the building would you
please leave the building via the
nearest available exit to the chamber
our assembly point will be in the public
carpark at the side of the Civic suite
please don't delay your belonging your
evacuation by collecting belongings
please don't return into the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please also note that the
meeting is audio recorded and as usual
if you have a phone put it on silent
please there is one small addendum to
tonight's meeting item 7.2 is everybody
seen that thank you very much right item
1 apologies for absence there are none
so therefore item to substitute members
that are non non members standing
counselor mr. hoi and councillor Stanley
sorry
beg your pardon unforgettable my mind
blank there for a moment
item 4 minutes of the meeting held on
14th of February 2019 happy for me to
sign those as a correct and accurate
record of that meeting thank you item 5
is declarations of interest
five six thank you can see honor
and when we get to that item you're
going to thank you caster set out caster
Williams Thank You chairman yeah
non-pecuniary interest on item six as
being on the Investment Board and item
7.2 knowing the applicant okay thank you
Cassie slept oh absolutely same disobey
I forgot in between got a curie interest
as member of the original project board
chairman of the investment board and i
shall be leaving the meeting for item
six thank you that's a wilson
that's that's a lot of weight and that
was item right then
so we now move on to item six so quite
quite happy if you hit stop and hear the
report the officers report okay mister
strength Thank You chairman this
application is to site we see here
located on the southern side of cage
field Road the site has been open and is
adjoining a block of four flats in this
building and eight flats opposite the
remainder of the site area is all
housing particularly local authority
stock design of around the nineteen
interwar period 1950s this application
is brought to the committee because the
council is the applicant if we can jump
to two please just to orientate yourself
with the aerial photograph sorry my
mistake
I'm stay on that no that's not the one
is it
bear with this mess
where's that going to
festival
okay bear with us chairman the site we
see is here and it's a cage filled road
junction with stand bridge wrote there
the Royal Oak Park down there torrent
ourselves and the new new housing in
this part our site is in there you'll
see the development pattern and what you
saw on the location plan earlier on if
we could jump to 3d please German this
site got outline Planning Commission in
March 2017 and here we see what we often
refer to you as an indicative plan and
you'll see actually how similar it is to
the plan that's going to be before you
tonight you'll see the site broadly
square in shape and at outline stage
there was a position of a building of
this design with the brickwork at the
lower levels with some bay interest
around the door and the white render at
the top you'll note this this depth at
this side when we dealt with the
application at outline stage there was
concern that the the depth was slightly
rearward of the adjoining flats you'll
know that your policy or guidance I
dearly seeks 35 meters distance back to
back for privacy reasons but obviously
with the presence of the flats next door
that only some 17 meters
rather undermined the argument we would
normally hold against upper floor living
the principal living rooms so what the
consent required was that the rear wall
area be set back to 17 meters consistent
with the adjoining flatted development
that seemed reasonable if we can jump to
four please
and this is the proposed site plan of
the actual building that's before you
tonight outline permission was granted
and this current application before you
is the reserve matters the second half
all the details of the building you'll
see what the applicant has done he's
shoved the building back to the 17
metres required more consistent with the
adjoining property and the car parking
has previously shown in the front part
of the building you'll notice that it's
got the 2.9 width but the depth of the
car parking space is only over 5 meters
it's not quite the five and a half
meters that your preferred standard
requires it does exceed the minimum
standard of five but it's the depth is
not at the 5 meters the width is the
width is at 2.9 meters the rear amenity
space why we're on this plan is 98
square meters big in the scheme of this
site which is one two-bedroom flat and
two one-bedroom flats would only require
75 so it's over that there's a it's
slightly under it's 0.98 meters on the
side space you recall that we do seek
ideally one meter distance but there's a
slightly wider side space to the
detached neighbor on this side so that
we feel that the to offset each other
particularly as that is a flatted scheme
so officers aren't saying that it's got
an inadequate space it's just a couple
of centimeters below your your normal
standard that you seek if we could jump
to five please the elevations members
will see now that almost like spot the
difference between the the previous
which was indicative that outline stage
you'll see that the appearance has been
retained with the tiled roof that the
renderer upper floor the brick details
and canopies at ground floor you'll see
the bin stores are provided in recesses
to the side of the buildings and the
flats have independent access is a
shared Lobby that goes up to one of the
upstairs rooms and an independent access
for that one on that side
the two-bedroom flat would be to the
ground floor and both one-bedroom flats
would be to the first floor the heights
of the building is about seven point
eight five meters which you'll see is
generally consistent with the adjoining
buildings that are shown the heights of
the walling that is to the eaves to the
underside of the roof is about five
point eight meters and again in keeping
with what's there the gross in terms of
the national space standards the design
and layout that you see here would
provide for the required cupboard
storage in each unit the one-bedroom
flats are in excess of the gross by
seven square meters the two-bedroom flat
is on the mark of what is required for
the gross so it's a fully compliant
scheme it's in excess of what's required
in the case of the one-bedroom the
proposed building would be of a design
and form as you can see in character
with what's already built in the
locality the recommendation is there for
approval subject to the conditions that
are set out in the report thank you so
this is just reserved matters does
anyone wish to comment on this one okay
well we'll move straight to the
recommendation for permission for
approval can I ask those members in
favor of approval to indicate then thank
you very much that is everyone as item
is approved could we come back in the
three please
so our next item is item 7 Juan referred
from the weekly list but from car by
Councillor our new clever ham cottage
pagglesham Road pagglesham Thank You
chairman good evening members this is a
resubmitted application further to the
refusal of an application in July 2018
which was planning application 1800 335
which is basically involves the
extension of residential curtilage so
this is club annum cottage here this is
the extent of the historic curtilage and
the application of all aged in red is
the whole of the current curtilage and
the dwelling and that the additional
area of land proposed as edge in red the
application relates this area
predominately to the north of the
existing curtilage
it's the timer's on account anything
right so right so what we have here is
the existing site plan what the what the
actual site plan indicates is the
existing stable block and we'll see some
elevation drawing so currently this site
in terms of its character what we have
at the North elevation is at the north
aspect of the site is a clearly defined
hedged boundary here the site is is
comprised of of a fence boundary along
here where there's a further area of
open land to the west and then we have
this stable block which is 26 meter long
stable block here and then this is the
historic curtilage there is a there was
a post and rail fence here at the time
the site visit back in 2018 and the site
is in terms of character it's actually
as of the last time observed it was more
grass so there was not much physical
distinction between the area of land so
at some point on its last norm planning
uses a neck wine use but from the
observations and the taken to the site
visit it was an area that you couldn't
physically define it actually from being
nothing other than an extension to the
curtilage I'm not saying that the actual
use had already begun but in terms of
its character and its nature it appeared
to be that of a Kurt similar to a
curtilage we just move on in terms of
just to give you some dimensions then
the existing stable block from the block
plan it is twenty six point eight nine
five meters in length it's three point
six nine zero meters in width and in
terms of its elevation there is there is
a little section actually at the top end
here that slightly wider but on the
majority of the of the elevation it is
that three point six nine zero meters in
width and in terms of its height you'll
see from the elevation drawings it's two
point six five
meters in height at its highest end and
2.2 meters at the lowest end at the rear
elevation we'll just move on the actual
site area just to explain there was a
discrepancy between the the planning
application form section for the
planning application form indicates it's
not pipe 1 hectares which is equates to
a thousand square meters it's not far
off the the plan indicates however that
the site is actually 910 meter square
but that's just the discrepancy that we
don't have an issue with it's just
matter pointing that out
okay just move on so we've seen the
existing plan and this is the proposed
block plan then which members will be
able to appreciate clearly that there is
a shorter the building is gonna be
shorter in length so that is a material
fact so in terms of the actual new
building that length and will be reduced
from twenty six point eight nine five
meters in length to thirteen point two
meters so that is what is actually
represented by that drawing there
basically it'll be four point eight
meters in width but that doesn't include
the the veranda elements which provides
a greater width and we can see that from
the elevation drawing that I'll show
members in a few seconds so in terms of
the existing elevations I'll have to
rotate this members view would say
and we rotate me I'll do it the other
way you rotate the so there we are so in
terms of the dimensions I gave members
earlier so that what we have is a very
linear stable this slight addition in
width at the northern air elevation of
the building so at the this is the front
elevation looking at it from the West so
that height there from ground level to
the level of the highest level of the
roof
so it has a slightly sloping roof as
members can appreciate from this section
drawing here so the the highest point is
two point six five meters which is at
the front here and then at the back it's
slightly lower
sorry I'm shaking slightly lower at 2.2
meters at the rear now and also in terms
of the site's itself the rear of the
stable actually is actually well framed
within it with a net with an edge
boundary here so in terms of when I come
on
to the assessment and the and the
conclusions in terms of there is a
clearly defensible boundary there so the
site being hedge on the northern cell
northern aspect the hedge on the eastern
aspect and then open to the existing
curtilage and then open to this further
area of open field that we have here
we'll just move on then so you can see
the elevation of the proposed building
for paused elevations just bear with me
I think that was the same apologies for
that proposed elevations so what we have
then is this building that I would say
that members will make of it what they
were but it resembles typically a sort
of a domestic looking building looks
familiar to buildings that you'd find in
cricket pavilions that kind of thing so
in terms of what members will see is so
the width just to clarify further what I
said previously so the main bulk of the
bill
the main bulk of it here from that there
too there is four points eight meters
but then there's this overhang so in its
totality it is six meters in width and
that is something I've see this is a key
material factor so in terms of its
height it is four meters in height as
compared to the two point six five zero
meters in height of the existing
building so that the purpose of this
building is clearly as per application
description is to serve a purpose which
is incidental to the enjoyment of the
dwelling-house that may serve that sort
of broad banner of use this you know may
serve a functional purpose of of
anything from a games room to it to a
sort of a an art studio and the
authority have no issue in terms of the
actual stated use whatsoever in terms
we're not sort of debating or querying
that it's use is nothing other than the
use that is incidental thing jeong's of
the dwelling house just move on we'll
show some images think this this is
what's quite important he wanted me to
show these photographs just bear with me
so there we go so that is a photograph
of the existing stable that was taken in
in July I wasn't aware of any material
change to the building I did pass the
site in the last two weeks and from
where I was looking I couldn't see any
drastic material change but I do
understand there has been there has been
some it alteration to the actual roof of
the building in terms of the roof
materials coming off but I can't
elaborate on that we have to gauge an
application on the basis of at the time
the application was submitted as
represented by the submitted plans and
whether a change in the physical fabric
of the building from the time that the
case was submitted to this point of
determination I would suggest members is
not a key material factor so that is the
photograph of the other site with this
Mord area from looking from the west and
there we go you can see the relationship
so in terms of what I indicated
regarding the the nature and the
character of the of the site what isn't
quite so clear as it would appear
although it's not a consideration this
evening there's an area of open field
here that resembles very much in terms
of its character and appearance an
extended long area but that is obviously
not part of this application and there's
no because of no interest to us at this
time so what we can see then is a is a
is a is a sort of a detached country
property and it's not unusual actually
to have realized cartilages serving
these properties and although the stable
building itself might have been viewed
as a use that was sort of incidental
thing Jones of the dwelling house it was
nevertheless a distinctive equine
planning unit hence this applications
have formally changed that equine use to
a formal incidental residential use so
this area comes packed becomes a formal
part of the residential planning units
I'm almost finished members these
photographs are quite helpful to enable
you that was the field I mentioned
previously which is an open area of
amenity land I would suggest to the west
of the site and there he goes so it's a
reasonable photograph actually showing
the the stable then in terms of what
what I would describe this table as it's
in it's in deniable II quite a long
building in length but it's it's what is
characteristic about it and I think what
the report alludes to in the assessment
is is that it's quite a ground hugging
building I'm not making any comments in
relation to its physical state or its
functionality clearly the applicants has
plans in terms of the utilization of
that land for another purpose but it's
it's quite a ground-hugging building I
would say at best I would say so
rudimentary sort of design simple timber
frame of Nohr
sort of particular architectural merit
and overlaid with boarding so very
functional for what its purpose was
originally oh yeah I think I'll leave
the I don't think there's nothing else
that I can show you in terms of the
photograph so I'll just go on to
conclude and to emphasize a few points
really the applicant did submit a
planning support statement the the
statement also referred to the
interpretation of the application the
first time it was submitted and the
report speaks to that planning statement
now fundamentally there are a few things
I just want to clarify with members what
the first question I think the main
points are covered from paragraph 23 to
32 of the report which I'm not going to
really repeat but it's an unusual
application in in a sense because the
authority due to the requirements of the
national planning policy framework which
is now paragraph 143 to paragraph 145 we
do have to consider whether the actual
building operation itself constitutes
inappropriate development and that is a
key factor that cited by the the MPP F
and what what the NPP F says is that any
Sur replacement building would be an
appropriate development if it wasn't
reacted in in a manner to serve the same
use so unfortunately due to the way that
the NPP F is actually written this the
actual building operation itself and the
replacement of an equine building with a
building which is to serve an incidental
residential use regardless of the change
of use that we're considering the report
indicates that actually by by definition
in the meaning of the NPP F unfortunates
in appropriate development we then have
to look at the other considerations to
say well okay
the starting point is it's inappropriate
development so by the default position
inappropriate development is not really
permitted within the Greenbelt unless
there are other materially overriding
factors which then justify the very
special circumstance to to justify the
development so it is a strange
application I will say in that respect
that the the policy wording and the
definition of policy is not kind to the
actual built form itself and just to
conclude on the building element of it
what the authority would concede is what
is a material fact is that the building
the replacement building is going to be
much shorter than the than the existing
stable but I think from the from the
report fundamentally it's the actual the
the building is higher and it also
entails that the that the proportions of
the building in terms of this increased
gable massing and the width basically so
notwithstanding the reduce reduction in
length I think what the report concludes
is that that in itself does not provide
the adequate mitigation to find this
development acceptable the one thing
also that seems to be key a key factor
in the determination of so if we put to
one side the inappropriate development
argument and just and just concentrated
on so it's inappropriate so therefore
the default position is its it's
contrary to policy effectively but if we
take it one step further and say right
ok it's a stable block being replaced
with a building so reason we we do have
to consider what is the material harm to
greenbelt openness regardless of the use
so we're looking at there's a reduction
in the length so one could argue that in
favor of of the actual arguments of
impact on Greenbelt openness
reduction in length would would
reasonably entail that there's less
impact but this isn't actually
adequately mitigated for the fact that
it's a much higher building it is
roughly one point three five meters
higher and what you have is a higher
eaves level it's not a ground hugging
building and just to conclude members it
is quite clear that a policy a theme
that runs through Greenbelt policy as a
whole whether its replacement buildings
in different uses previously developed
land development where perhaps a stable
has been knocked down in favor of a of a
bungalow the theme that emerges through
all of these various scenarios that you
may get get in the Greenbelt is that the
building it replaces mustn't be
materially larger or have any greater
effect on the character the of the
openness of Greenbelt than the building
it replaces
so in conclusion recognizing that this
isn't a straight four application by
virtue of the height of the building and
the increase
width of the building this actually
would be harmful to the Greenbelt that's
the judgment that the authorities made
it's a judgment that is as previously
made in relation to the application
refused last year we've considered the
planning statement issued by the by the
applicant in great detail and the report
speaks to that in terms of justifying
the authority's position with regards to
the point made in the planning statement
so on the basis of how the MPP F is
worded and on the authority's
interpretation of impact upon Greenbelt
openness merely and purely informed ly
by reason of the height of the building
its width it would actually have a
greater impact upon Greenbelt openness
than the existing building and that is
also a key theme that seems to be
supported in planning inspectors
decisions on this kind of scenario so
reluctantly Chad's is my recommendation
that the application be refused thank
you
we have mr. Denton is going to speak on
this one thank you feel free sit down
thank you thank you for your time this
evening I'll I'll be brief my family and
I are long-term local residents my wife
and I grew up in Hockley and we moved to
penguin having had that as a long-term
aspiration moved to penguin two and a
half years ago and we love everything
about it
we have turned an unloved empty house
into a lovely family home and we've made
the outside space as you've seen a
secure and safe place for our two boys
over there and two dogs the plane so
Noah is the older one with the Kyle is
the younger one over there as you've
heard we're now looking to make the best
use of the dilapidated stable block
whilst it is a stable according it that
just covers up a an attractive image the
staple is anything but that as you've
heard it's a 27 meter felt roofed
twisted 1980s built shed which has seen
part of its roof collapse when we bought
the property in 2016 the roof at the end
of the property had collapsed
our hopes were to replace the stable
with a log-cabin of less than half the
length as you've heard the proposed
outbuilding would provide a games room
for the kids and their friends we want
to get a pool table a football table
we've already got a table tennis table
and that would provide an opportunity
for us to get several children of the
area away from their games consoles all
at once we are aware of the challenges
you face in protecting Rochford screen
belt the openness of the green belt is
the key reason that we now live in it so
you can see why we thought that rather
than introducing more buildings into the
garden we thought it would be a good
idea to replace an existing unattractive
building in the same location rather
than introduce a new one in another
location we thought using previously
developed land was a good thing the
proposed outbuilding would be a simpler
and modest timber structure a log cabin
which would significantly reduce the
amount of built form in the space where
the stable currently stands given this
information I cannot see how this
proposal harms the openness of the
countryside and the Greenbelt it is
surrounded by trees and can't be seen
from the road we tried to work closely
with the planning officers and welcome
their support for the proposed curtilage
extension thank you however it is
unclear to us why an outbuilding which
is half the footprint and length of the
existing stable on previously developed
land is considered to result in harm to
the Greenbelt we really thought that we
were doing a positive thing if we had
known it had been this difficult we
would have used our permitted
development rights and put another
building in the Greenbelt in our
existing garden this would mean 40
linear meters of buildings instead of
the 13 that we are proposing or the 27
that are there now we do not want to
exercise the fallback position which
we've been using our permitted
development rights resulting in two
buildings instead
smaller building we're even willing to
give up our permitted development rights
in the process we therefore would really
welcome your support thank you Thank You
councillor Stanley I'd like to start
where's thank you chairman because of
its because of its height and depth it's
obviously a substantial building but I
just wonder why we need something four
meters high if he's four children has
just been saved why four meters high why
why can't it be a little bit lower so
then sort of blend in as the stable
block already does with the surrounding
areas
my question is to the officer the back
of it is absolutely plain so it would
there's no sort of any sort of contrast
that's going on in the back you suddenly
the front that's that's thing it gives
it gives it character sort of thing is
it's the construction of the building
applicable in this particular case how
its devotees put together I've just been
told it's going to be a log cabin is
this anything different to what to the
regulations always is it does it have
you know is it have to conform to
anything in design yeah briefly on
so in interns answer that question the
authority is satisfied that it is
operational developments so it's a
building operation as defined in Section
55 of the tunnel country Planning Act
it's not a caravan it's not something
that's actually resting on a chassis of
any kind the the planning application
did submit some I do have some sectional
drawings actually to answer that
question you bear with me proposed
section drawing actually would address
your question so clearly there's going
to be a concrete raft foundation or a
concrete transportation so in terms of
its bill there's going to be substantial
building so in terms of looking at it
yes I think one wouldn't be able to
distinguish probably just looking at the
elevation plan whether it's a caravan or
a-- or something more substantial but in
terms of actually the reason why the
application has been refused it's based
purely on its height and the increased
width and massing that that creates in
itself
that's the mr. Howie Thank You chairman
look at the plains are just just a
couple of points one is that clearly
it's with regard to the MPP F statement
next it E is a problem but also I think
mine either the height of it is the
issue in relation to the property or the
building which was there before and I
think without a doubt if the this
building didn't have the height it has
it wouldn't be a problem moving on from
that I think this is probably the first
time in my years of the councilor I've
heard an officer refer to an unfortunate
wording in the NPP F and also the first
time I've heard an officer say that with
reluctance they are remaking
recommending a report and I don't
necessarily think that's appropriate
thank you Jim
I'll know Thank You chairman the
planning application which comes from
mr. Trevor dent Denton who lives with
his family at Cleveland and cottage the
application focuses on a small pass of
land to the rear of the existing a
gardener also owned by mr. Denton it was
used as an equestrian paddock but it
hasn't been for some time now the
paddock contains a large stable building
which has been on the site since the
1980s we're planning permission was
granted in 1983 I've heard that the
stable building has fallen into
disrepair and mr. Denton would like to
replace it and use it in conjunction
with the cottage for example as a
playroom
although Senator Jim space by the family
I understand from officers that the
proposed inclusion of this land within
the residential curtilage is acceptable
officers agree that the paddock is
indistinguishable from the main garden
and would be will screened by existing
boundaries treatments if this is in the
case and permission were granted for the
curtilage extension then the existing
building which is the subject of this
application would be would be come and
will become a sinner II to the existing
cot cottage I understand from reading
Nigar officer's report that the proposal
site lies in the Greenbelt the officers
report makes reference to chapter 13 of
the NPP F which states that the
inappropriate development is by
definition harmful to green built and
should not be approving except in the
very special circumstances however in
the same chapter at paragraph 145
exemptions to Himmler proferred develop
are listed it seems to me that what is
proposed for
within two of these exemptions exemption
D was considered by officers and
dismissed because the building is not in
the same use as the proposed incidental
outbuilding but of course it would be in
the event the curtilage extent was
granted I go back to my previous point
that officers do not object to the
curtilage extension
I noticed that officers have not
considered X exemption G which allows
the complete redevelop our previously
developed land permitted it does not
have a great impact on the openness of
the Greenbelt then the existing
development from the plan submitted I
see that our bidding would be cited in
some location within the plot as as the
existing stable building 39 percent
smaller footprint half the length of
this existing stable whilst the ridge
height will be higher garroted lee the
building is smaller and therefore its
visual impact can only be less I also
understand that a structure of this size
could be built in existing garden under
permitted development rights without
planning permission as well as retaining
the stable buildings instead mr. Denton
is simply seeking to make use of
existing built footprints rather than
introducing another building it is happy
for the class a permitted development
rise to be removed by their planning
condition so there any more buildings in
the GAR will need planning permission
currently they don't what you have been
presented with and with is an
opportunity to make use of previously
developed land whilst regaining the
ability to control further and ciliary
residential development in the Greenbelt
I cannot see how this proposal results
in harming the openness of the Greenbelt
counselor iris seems to be reading from
a prepared skip script
can we please confirm that he has not
predetermined this case no I haven't
been
so so jerk jerk just for for formalities
sake can't cancel on it yes can you
confirm that the notes that you've used
have not been part of a predetermined
view that you've come to that you have
come to the meeting to carefully
consider all of the other evidence has
been presented for you they are to you
and other members tonight that is
correct
thank you castor hoc way thank you
cheering that I've got a couple of
questions for the officers regards to
the photograph that we see Tom it's on
with regard to the photograph that we
have before him before us there the line
of trees does that form the boundary
between the existing curtilage of the
property and the boundary between the
land which is deemed to be green belt
land
hmm we've gone to the photograph before
us now there is a line of trees which
cuts across the property the land these
this does that form the boundary between
the the curvature of the property and
the land which you seemed to be part the
green Balki it's yes it's all Greenbelt
anyways answer in terms of the distinct
welling and the historic curtilage so in
terms answer that question I wouldn't be
able to say for sure that those trees
that we see there are actually they may
be consistent but but as of this time
it's very difficult to actually
ascertain exactly where the the the
historic curtilage is so I wouldn't be
able to confirm that that line of trees
precisely marked the definitive historic
curtilage but I guess that they're not
too far off where the boundary used to
be but I couldn't confirm that another
question is the existing building been
described as being dilapidated although
in the report contradicts that if the
building was renovated as long as it was
used for retcon use there wouldn't be
any issue planning issues if it was
renovated and converted into a form of
residential that would require planning
permission is that correct that yeah
that is correct
so in so in terms of yeah the
refurbishment of that building Fike when
you strip air for the purpose of Italian
Country Planning Act isn't developed in
itself but but basically it would be
possible to - nothing that'd be possible
to renovate up building but if that
building was if a new building for
example was erected or there was a this
building was was retained in some form
then the the yes it would be subject to
the material change of use when it from
the equine used to an incidental
residential use this has already come
before this committee previously what
material changes has occurred to the
application in relation to what we had
before us before and what he's now
before us now since the answer is simply
there are no material changes and
therefore that is consistent with a
recommendation that was made the first
time around what I will add is that the
report does speak to the planning
statement the planning statement
actually sets out that on the first
report that the measurements of the
building had reported were incorrect and
my report this time around does point
out the fact that those measurements
were based on the drawings submitted so
there was a discrepancy within the scale
drawing but as of your question it's as
of the opening of my presentation it's
entirely the same application which the
applicant seeks to justify the second
time around this was another place we
would be calling this meaning go
meaningful vote - we had in the West
there's Thank You chairman come just a
question really I understand I agree
with part of what my fellow councillor
George
Ayano was saying and I understand that
what this gentleman is trying to achieve
for this family in question I'd like to
start a sketch in' if this was not
granted tonight refused tonight and the
applicant went to appeal and is it
likely to get a grant I'm not too sure
is it likely to be granted on appeal
because I'm just more concerned of what
it's gonna cost RDC say that that that
is not for us to consider tonight we
cannot take a judgment on how an
independent inspector my mark might act
okay thanks Joan cancel mrs. Howe no
need to stand firm it may be for
chairman it would be a unless anything
is moved differently it would be the
recommendation for fruit for refusal
that's printed on seven point one point
ten Thank You councillor Steptoe Thank
You chairman I've listened to the
arguments with great interest here and I
would like to propose that we accept the
planning application on the basis of the
it it's not any appreciable increase in
detriment to the the Greenbelt area and
as the applicant has already suggested
in his in his piece that the any further
permitted development rights are removed
thank you do you have a seconder mark
we've got take your pick
councillor Mel okay
so members we have a move for approval
on this one cancel our new you indicated
you like to come back anyway yes just to
clarify for mr. Hawke way the actual
application was not presented to this
cabinet last year it was refused by
officers unfortunately due to
circumstance out of our control the
application was not called in in their
appropriate time limit mrs. Howe if we
just all have a look at the acts it's a
lot lengthy paragraph paragraph 28
remote removing permitted development
rights okay cancer stepped o8 there's no
one else indicating at the moment so can
you make this your summing up and
include your restatement but
particularly because it's green bell
allow officers to understand the
circumstances that allow you to put
forward your okay Thank You chairman I'd
like to move that it is no appreciable
difference in the detrimental view or
the area of the green belt and that the
primitive development rights are removed
which i think is probably covered by our
item 2085 read that very quickly and
correctly can I check that officers have
necessary understanding of what's women
okay
those members in favor of the approval
please indicate those against that item
is carried thank you
we go onto our last item tonight which
again it's got the small addendum
Hillview or Boston Road Ashington who's
taking this one
mr. strengths Thank You chairman this
application is to site on the northern
side of overstand Road shown in the
hatched area here the property that
relates to is Hill view which is marked
there and this this plan is important to
show you the sporadic nature of where
the site is located plot land that
members will be familiar with and made
roads plots varying size some with
buildings on some not some well-kept
some overgrown if we can jump to the
local plan extract please so the site if
you just get back to that that's it
local planning strategy to the site
you'll see is located in the Greenbelt
which is up here on the edge of the
settlement here's the aerial part is the
full area that we had on part of the
plan just now you'll see dissected by
several roads that are unmade and the
very nature of Blokland Ashington school
tour and take yourself is here the
Ashington Road here the edge of the
built-up area of Ashington
at this point here shown in the white
the purpose of this plan is to show you
the green the P green shading which
represents the Greenbelt policy area and
you'll see that this site are though not
affected by it is on the edge of the
coastal protection belt that's a
protection policy to safeguard the views
of the landscape from the undeveloped
coastline this this application does not
impinge on the coast of protection belt
that's just to explain some of the
notations that you'll see above you the
important one is that this site is in
the green belt you'll see which washes
over the whole area yeah if we can see
the proposed plan please the planning
application is retrospective it involves
the change of use of an area of land a
plot of land adjoining this site
to garden thank you here's the site of
Hill view the existing dwelling and
we're considering tonight the change of
use of this area adjoining that plot to
use as a garden it's enclosed with a
closed boarded fence along the side open
at the back overlooking the farmland and
there's another fence line not shown
through here and some outbuildings as
well but the application before use
principally the change of use of that
land if we could jump to the previous
aerial view I can't date this for
members but I think it predates 2011
this shows you the site of Hill view the
dwelling itself and this is the
adjoining plot of land that we're
talking about tonight you'll see it's
got varying cover some grassland some
hedge boundaries and margins and there's
the open farmland at the back and you'll
see there's a flavor of the settlements
again some of it with hedges some of it
open some with quite intense forms of
development some completely bare that's
the nature of this of this area if we
now jump to the current law a little bit
more recent aerial image please should
be slightly higher up in altitude
chairman but our site is is this one
here here we see Hill view and you'll
see that by this time the photograph was
taken the land was enclosed and you'll
see that the plot is wider and closely
mon tidy lawn
domestic in character if we can stick
with that for the moment please members
will see from the officer report that
policy 22 in your development management
plan sets down criteria for helping of
consideration of applications to change
the use of land to be incorporated into
existing gardens it says in the preamble
that you'll say that the policy clearly
argues that garden extensions can be
visually harmful to openness of the
Greenbelt added to this can be the
impact of domestic outbuildings and
other paraphernalia such as fencing
excepting this only where such proposal
may align with a neighboring fencing so
imagine if this was a dogleg staggered
arrangement and there was a neat
boundary at the back and it might be
that a pocket
of a fencing and garden extension would
align like these do but we're talking of
a plot to the side of the existing
property as are there are many plots
scattered about between the dwellings in
the area
the preamble argues that such garden
extension will be permitted only where
the impact is minimal taken into account
the size of the garden extension it
should be not out of proportion to the
original that exists an example is given
a paragraph 3.8 2 of the policy that's
not in your report that the doubling of
the size of the garden should be avoided
now if we concede that to the plan 3 the
proposed site plan members will see from
the report that the actual land area
involved here is more than doubling the
size of the gardener it represents a
hundred and seventy four percent of the
size of this existing plot so therefore
it conflicts with policy DM 22 and added
to that there's the urban style fencing
concrete gravel boards and closed
boarded paneling that you see typically
in built-up urban areas and officers
conclude that that by itself is also
visually harmful as well on the addendum
members will say that Ashenden Parish
Council has raised our objection into
the application the recommendation is
refusal for the reasons you see set out
in the report thank you we have a
speaker on this one mr. Ward
five minutes late you know when you got
to go sit down it's not you can hear me
there's good evening chair members thank
you for calling all applications to
committee for discussion while playing
application was submitted back in July
18 and it's very disappointing after
waiting nine months for a decision the
planning officer has recommending
application for refusal I've lived at a
property for over 25 years in the work
very hard to keep the property in the
surrounding grounds attractive in early
2011 I was given the opportunity to
purchase additional land next to my
property
this land was severely I were grown for
several years with broken fencing and
gates he had no beneficial use and was
left vacant for a long time with no one
maintaining the land it detracted from
my property and the character and
appearance of the area and made
absolutely no positive contribution to
the setting so when the land came up for
sale or purchased it Eileen spent a
considerable amount of time and money
clearing the site cutting back the other
grind scrub land and planting seed for
grass I hired a professional fencing
company to replace the existing broken
fencing but a close ball dispensed with
concrete posts the fencing is tidy and
attractive and allows me to have
adequate privacy by July 2011 works were
complete and I photographic evidence
which is dated in 2011 showing a both
the fencing and the sheds referred to in
the offices report were in existence by
that date and the remained for the past
seven years they form a fundamental part
of the character of the area I have been
using this Lane this area of land for my
enjoyment as my garden since that time
the officer himself acknowledged in his
report that I think that he's been in
place for quite some time and they're
not clear when the change of use
occurred I can confirm that the change
of use was over seven years ago in 2011
I genuinely had no idea we required the
planning permission to erect the fencing
or the sheds or to officially change the
use of land from a goal
the fencing does not exceed two meters
and the outbuildings also comply with a
permitted development requirements in
the spring of last year our proactively
approached the council for
pre-application advice and following a
planning I was made aware at a planning
meeting that I needed planning
permission for the works carried out and
the use of the land as my garden there
for planning permission has now been
sought with suggested by the council if
I had not approached the council in my
situation would have remained as
existing it seems to me like I'm being
penalized for trying to do the right
thing it's my understanding that as as
the fencing in sheds would be defined as
building operations were completed over
seven years ago that they have become
lawful development exempt from
enforcement action if they can remain it
is confusing to me why the officer
attaches great focus on the harm that
the fence causes to the Greenbelt the
description of the area in the report is
very misleading and makes it sound like
my property is an isolated dwelling
surrounded by countryside I do not
accept that I'm in a rural surroundings
as a report claims my property and the
land subjects of this application is
well contained between existing
developments so the east of my site is a
1.5 story residential dwelling which has
recently undergone significant
alterations and extensions so the West
is an awfully established business with
various buildings and commercial
activity the northern boundary does have
open countryside however there is no
Claude clothes Baldy fencing the longest
boundary and it remains open the officer
claims that the fence results in a
highly urban appearance however what the
report fails to highlights are members
is that there are several examples of
the same high clothes Baldy fencing with
concrete posts or National Park estates
there is no difference between my
boundary treatment and several other
examples I'm hopeful that some of you
members know these this area will and
will be fully aware of the boundary
treatments in the area so name just a
few other properties Eversleigh as a
high brick wall
well over six feet high along the front
boundary and a large area of the site is
enclosed by high closed ball defense
with concrete posts similar to mine
yeah Alma this property has a high close
Baldy defensive on the boundary clearly
visible on the road frontage my boundary
treatment is set back significantly
further from the road than this fence
flickin lodge is a modest bungalow with
a very large plot area to the site which
is secured by a high closed ball defense
why take a cottage is another example
I'd like to draw my members attention to
this is a modest bungalow with a large 1
acre garden to the side which is also
contained by close bollard things I do
not understand why the assessment of my
proposal is any different from any of
these developments I cannot help feeling
singled out when all these properties of
all some in the Greenbelt and no harm
has been identified with any of these
other dwellings the report recognizes
that rural areas Greenbelt properties
have spacious plots this is true of the
development in my area many of the
modest bungalows have large garden areas
some located to the side of the property
the same as my land subjects of this
application there is no difference
between my property in the surrounding
development so I do not agree that my
proposal would result in an urbanizing
effects
the area is already relatively built up
and the granting of this permission was
not result in urban sprawl which is now
which is a general aim green pill policy
seeks to avoid if members are not
familiar with the area
I would ask rather than agree with the
officers recommendation that this
application be deferred and other
members can and members can carry out a
visitor surrounding area I'm gonna have
to stop you there now I've only got one
little bit honestly and then if you are
aware of the character of the area I ask
that you please overturn officers
recommendation and grant me my planning
permission so that I can continue to
enjoy the name which I've spent a
considerable amount of time and money
and make an attractive please also
consider that there has not been any
objections whatsoever from any
other surrounding neighbors thank you
thank you very much for listening all
right counselor Stanley you're indicated
Thank You chairman from the can we go
back to the photos please yeah you carry
on this on the aerial photo where this
land is being cultivated no not that one
the one that shows the gardens whichever
one that was I think you're gonna have
to carry on this okay okay
so dead what on the on the boundary
where the boundary fence is I'd like to
ask is there he can't get it it is there
any hedging or ah there we go
right so it the boundary on the of the
next boundary which shows a dark area
other than the fencing that is a
hedgerow of some songs is it I'm
thinking I'm thinking more of nesting
birds and what-have-you so this side
this side yeah that's it that's it yeah
thats a hater Oh easy yes chairman yes
the dark lion if I may although way the
shade of the fence that's B although
that's the fate as long as the
intervening plot of land and then
there's the hedgerow you've got a
hedgerow there yeah all what I was going
to say was that as there is a large
hydro there then putting that fence line
up hasn't deteriorated from the urban if
you like nor the wild part of the
property as that is there for
but nesting birds and what have you so I
don't see any problem with this
application at all in fact I think it's
a a well thought out and good use of of
the lane rather than being just as a
shrubs just basically a wild shrubs
shrubbery sort of thing where where it's
not cultivated or anything so I think
that's a good good use of the lane plus
the fact that they were all hate other
hedgerows there which always concerned
about thank you okay this item was
referred by councillor Williams okay
thank you do you have some sympathy with
the applicant they only mind the amount
of time since he acquired the land and
made made alterations and the money
spent I also have other concerns about
how we have set policy and that you know
we should be looking to stick to our
policy and not allow just simply the
passage of time to dictate whether we
should ignore that policy or not thank
Jeff heavily heavily torn on this for
two reasons one I'm sure members are
aware of my feelings of red spective
applications although I do genuinely
believe the applicant on this occasion
for the causes of them and the second
reason for being torn is is a bit
similar to councillor look way out I'm
confused as to how we apply policy
therefore in this case and there doesn't
seem to be a fence across the northern
boundary and as I've misunderstood and
the boundary to
the East defense that has been put up
does have trees the other sides to kind
of protect that fence from from view at
this stage I guess I would ask the
officers to remind me that the height of
that fence on the eastern boundary but
if they if a building that is four
meters tall isn't of damage to the to
the Greenbelt is a hidden fence of
similar Heights damage to the Greenbelt
[Music]
but any other members wishing to speak
on this one has to step down okay Jeff
again I think this is an application
that we should consider taking fort and
I'd be quite happy to propose that we
accept the application it's already on
the ground it's not caused any
particular issues to the surrounding
area and I don't consider it to be
detrimental to the Greenville so you say
move so move any there was talk about
permitted development rights and things
to step toe
we can ask what the permitted
developments are currently at the moment
we refer to officers please thank you
Thank You chairman the permitted
development rights at issue here are
those what they call Class A and Class F
which is the rights for outbuilding
swimming pools things like this and
class F which is hard surfaces at
parking areas tennis courts things like
that so what would happen is members
reminded to grant planning permission
there would be effectively extending the
garden and then with that comes the
residential user rights to do
outbuildings up to 50% coverage if the
applicant was so minded up to four
meters and three meters in Heights two
and a half meters in height where within
two meters of the of the boundary and
hard surfaces again with any other
buildings or whatever that again doesn't
don't total more than 50% of the garden
area just ask if we remove permitted
development rights that's only on the
piece of the enlargement of the garden
is that correct
yes chairman the site of your planning
application is the area edged here okay
bear in mind some members can't
determine read but the if I follow here
look this is the site of the planning
application which is the change of use
you couldn't I think reasonably improves
those rights on the existing dwelling
because whilst it's used in association
with that the use of that dwelling
itself is not is not a matter before you
you're you're being asked to consider
whether it's acceptable to use this area
of land for residential purposes and if
in your weighing up you come to the view
that you find that acceptable but are
concerned that with that use would come
baggage in the forms of loads of
outbuildings potentially garages things
like that which you then feel feel might
harm the Greenbelt if you feel that that
could be overcome by the use of a
condition bring in those buildings
within control and those surfaces within
control then that would have the
appropriate condition that you could
you could add I'm happy to include that
within the planning so just for clarity
as we continue members we have a move to
give this application planning
permission with usual conditions but
particularly the removal of permitted
development rights on that side okay
okay
so just just that wall okay counselor
hawk why are you indicated again yeah I
think it was just in relation to the
issue of the permitted development sort
of like matter so I think that's been
dealt with thank you
does any other member wish to speak
officers are clear on what counsel
Wilson thanks Jenna it's it's really a
query about in the future how would you
actually know where the boundary of this
site was chairman from a planning point
of view the use that you are thinking of
consenting to would be dictated by this
plan this this area edged here is
possibly tonight depending how you
decide being given a permission to use
of land now ownership and boundary is a
completely different matter what you
would have to look at is the deeds and
sometimes with some of these rural
properties you may get a property like
this that may have two or three deep
packs for some unknown reason whereas
it's like a jigsaw now it may well be
that some of this land is in varying
deep packs as well it's not a not a
planning matter because if you found
that some ownership strayed over and
things like that is sometimes the case
particular on old plots and things it's
a nightmare
all this committee concerns itself with
these the actual planning use and this
is clear on a quite up-to-date accurate
plan that says if members decide tonight
to grant plan admission it says the area
aged here he's now authorized as garden
extension to that regardless of the
ownership of boundaries if ditches have
been dug and whose the spoil is Honor I
don't think members need to concern
themselves with boundaries one thing I
can assure you is a planning permission
site there's not always a line to what
becomes the boundary that's just a
matter of legal fact I don't if my
colleague on the far end can help
clarify that if there's a need but my
experience is that the two aren't
necessarily always the same in plains
you're very lucky if you find a planning
permission that is exactly the same as
the deed pact
I think we probably don't want to
confuse the issue any further tonight
get into a technical discussion if
there's a condition around the the
development rights of the right hand
piece but we can't identify where the
right hand piece becomes the left hand
piece always we can quite clearly
identify the location via that red line
on a properly scale and drawing which is
part of the application cool thank you
thank you so members we have a mover for
approval on this on this application
with condition relating to permitted
development rights being removed and the
basis that it's not considered that the
demonstrable harm to the green belt is
is significant to create a refusal so
those members in favor of the approval
please indicate those against that item
is approved thank you very much that's
all tonight